[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to
uh cms colloquium um and
uh today we welcome james nguyen who is
associate professor of english and
rhetoric at carnegie mellon university
his research in teaching explores
science mathematics and public policy
from a rhetorical perspective his first
book evolution by the numbers examines
how mathematics
was argued into the study of variation
evolution and heredity in the late 19th
and early 20th centuries
his most recent monograph citizen
science in the digital age
explores how the internet and internet
connected devices
are reshaping the landscapes of argument
occupied by
scientists laypersons and governments
currently well today i think right saw
the publication
of arguing with numbers um
co-edited a volume that that professor
winco
edited a collection of essays co-edited
with gene mitchell reyes
whose contributors investigate the
relationship between rhetoric and
mathematics
uh he is also working on a new book
project on the rhetoric of mars
colonization
um from which he'll be drawing in
today's talk
um so uh welcome james and and
um i will pass things over to you
thank you so much vivek for the
introduction um i wanna i wanna
acknowledge and thank um ed shiapa who
is faculty
at mit um and i also want to acknowledge
that
the uh collection that is coming out
today
um ed has a chapter in that um so he is
also part of that
that wonderful project so i want to
thank him for his participation and
for inviting me here today to talk to
everybody about another project i've
been working on
um also um i want to thank you andrew
um for setting everything up for the
logistics making this all happen making
sure my slides work
everything thank you for doing that and
be back thanks for the introduction and
also for being moderator
today in our conversation so um as vivek
mentioned
what i'm going to talk about today is
actually some a new project that i've
been working on
um in particular the first chapter of
this book
um about mars colonization and so what i
want to share with you today
is a little bit about my research
project
my methods and concepts and also done a
little bit about my findings
so far now there are lots of things that
i'm interested in and i've
i've worked on in the book so you don't
need to sort of
if you have questions about other things
i'm happy to answer them
um but you know i'll focus today on just
one part of the project that i've been
working on
so i'm going to try i'm going to share
my slides here
um and then i think we can go from there
uh are these slides visible can
everybody see them
okay great thanks thank you all right
excellent
so i'm just gonna make sure i can get
the full screen
so the title of my talk today is
promotional narrative science fiction
and the case for colonization so
there are a few things i'd like to talk
about today first of all why mars
colonization
why is this particular topic exigent
right now why is it worth thinking about
or talking about
also some of the concepts and methods
that i'm using to do the analysis that
i'm going to share with you today
and of course my findings the the the
the
sort of themes or issues that are that
developed out of the analysis that i've
done
and finally discussion um this is going
to be on my part very brief because i
want to have a larger discussion with
everything
everyone about the topics i'm covering
in my talk
i'm thinking that this will probably
take about 40 minutes to to talk through
my slides and to uh
to show my evidence and discussion and
hopefully we'll have a really nice
discussion after that so i wanted to
just talk a little bit about the public
exigence for this work in other words
why am i interested in it
why do i think it's something that we
should be paying attention to right now
so first of all you know just two months
ago perseverance landed on mars and
there's been a lot of hoopla and
discussion about
that particular moment of of
um getting involved with mars and taking
the next steps towards
sending people there um in two in 2010
so essentially the last five years
there's been a lot of political movement
towards mars colonization or actually i
should say that in the last decade
there's been a lot of movement towards
um actually devoting government
resources
towards sending humans to mars
and making mars sort of a priority
project for nasa
so um in a speech in 2010
um at kennedy space center um
obama said for example that by the mid
2030s
um we will be sending humans into orbit
around mars and return them safely
and then landing on mars will follow
president trump actually signed the nasa
transition authorization act
which was developed under obama and then
it was signed as one of the first things
that trump did when he came into office
and within that particular uh
document that that act um there is an
explicit language
that the whole one of nasa's main goals
is to achieve the human exploration of
mars and beyond and just sort of
prioritize this
and everything it does so in other words
if they're going to build technology
um it should with it should be built
with forethought about going to mars
and how this is going to impact that
project so in other words
a lot of the planning for nasa is now
everything sort of
is related to mars and is about going
toward
going to mars also of course we
um can't forget the interest in the
private sector in mars
particularly of course uh elon musk and
jeff bezos
uh who have started their own rocket
companies and have begun to privatize
uh space travel um which has some
important implications i think for this
of of these two of course elon musk is
is very very interested in mars
causation
um and is hoping to see this in his
lifetime
uh if you go to musk's webpage of spacex
there's a particular section on mars and
in this section he has this quote
you want to wake up in the morning and
think that the future is going to be
great
and that's what being a space-faring
civilization is all about
i can't think of anything more exciting
than being out there and being amongst
the stars
so um elon musk is very sanguine about
mars and that's sort of one of his
his main goals and main priorities in
the development of his technology and
his company
um before i sort of get into the the
data and the methods that i want to use
i want to just step back for a second
and talk a little bit about the
disciplinary perspective i'm coming from
um professor shiap and i share rhetoric
as our disciplinary lens that we look at
things through
um essentially when i go to cocktail
parties and people ask me well
what is it you do and i say well i'm a
professor of rhetoric
and then they ask me well what do
rhetoricians do um i like to explain
that rhetoric
is sort of the the study of argument in
all of its splendor
and what by what i mean by that is that
rhetoricians are really interested
um unlike some other fields that study
argumentation
and really the broad range of persuasive
means including emotions including
arguments from the character of people
of the speaker
um and of course looking at these things
in various contexts and across different
kinds of media
so for my for this project i thought
i became very interested in colonization
sort of generally
but specifically because i study
rhetoric of science and public policy
um from the perspective of thinking
about colonization
in the context of mars colonization
so from a disciplinary perspective i
want to talk a little bit about the
contribution i think that my project is
making
in the field of rhetoric um most studies
of colonization
in rhetoric and in other fields that are
that are closely associated with it
think about colonization as a completed
act
or thinking about the impacts of
colonization
after they happen what i'm really
interested in though
is thinking about colonization in these
very early moments where
and i call these moments proto-colonial
moments because
in these moments the colonial enterprise
is very fragile and uncertain
so typically when people talk about
colonialism they look at
already established colonial projects
ones that have succeeded
but i'm interested in those projects in
very early stages when people aren't
sure that they're going to succeed
and they also need to really rely on
argumentation to get to persuade people
to really think about engaging in these
projects
so some questions i'm really interested
in are one
you know what are the rhetorical
challenges for the colonizer
how do you get people to buy into
colonial projects at a very early stage
um and also then how do previous
colonial acts
influence present colonial acts and
finally
you know what do we learn by contrasting
colonial proto-colonial moments
if we and so for my project in
particular i want to look at
um the colonization of north america so
these colonial moments and then
juxtapose those with
um this proto-colonial moment we're
having now um
thinking about colonizing mars
in order to in order to talk about these
things though i think it's important to
have
um sort of a set definition or a
definition that i'm gonna be
operationalizing or using in my research
of what colonialism is
so in particular what i'm talking about
is physical colonialism
um and what i mean by that are the
movement of people
from what are called source communities
or metropolitan communities
into um which are where they come from
into these target spaces
or target communities which are foreign
places
and also movements of people where
they're moving into these spaces and
they
they are intending to permanently reside
in those spaces
so there's a lot of um there's a lot of
uh rhetorical back and forth and sort of
arguing about
colonialism as versus imperialism
um so a lot of the discussions revolve
around the permanency
of of these versus imperialism which
tends to be less permanent
and there's sort of a shuffling of
bureaucratic and military folks into a
space and then sheltering them out again
um another important feature of
colonialism
which differentiates it from other kinds
of movements of people
um is that there is a notion where that
the people that are going to these
foreign spaces
maintain political identity and rely on
the original state for
their identity their protection the
resources they need to sort of
maintain their colonial presence in this
target community
so these are some very basic um
definitional qualities that i'm using
when i'm when i'm talking about what a
colony is
and what colonialism is one of the
things that's also important to this
project and this isn't something that
i've
i found in my research on defining
colonialism or talking about what it
means
is this this idea of stages of
colonialism so by reading
a lot of colonial tracts um it emerged
for me that there are different stages
of colonialism
the first stage is what i call the
exploration stage which is essentially
you send out
um uh people
or in the case of mars instruments um
that are there to sort of understand
that the resources and the conditions of
of the the space that is and and to
decide
whether it has potential for
colonization then you have a planting
stage which is where you put small
outposts there
if you think back to the early colonial
period in north america
um these were typically forts um with
military folks
um that were there to establish a
foothold
um but they weren't sort of full blown
colonies
and next of course you have the
settlement phase which is where um
these forts begin to expand and we get
different sorts of
of people um that begin to live there so
children
um women people from different walks of
life
like you know blacksmiths and and and
barrel makers and so forth right so it's
not just sort of a military operation
but it's a diversified
um more um heterogeneous population
and finally the very last stage of
colonialism is of course when
it disappears so it either disappears
through emancipation so
uh in the united states obviously after
the after the war for
independence the united states became
its own country so it was emancipated
from its original colonial source or
it's incorporated so you can think about
ireland and scotland for example
which became part of britain in the
united kingdom
um and so therefore there's sort of like
two ways it can go
you can either emancipate or you can
become incorporated and you lose your
status as a colony
for this particular project i looked at
two sets of texts so as a rhetorician we
study
typically artifacts and typically
written artifacts
um one set of texts i looked at are what
are called promotional literature and
i'll say a little bit about what that
means and what that is
so i looked at and as at 10 different
texts
which are examples of promotional
literature from the 16th and 17th
century
um and particularly during the english
proto-colonial period of the settlement
of north america
from about 1495 to 1650.
i also then looked at modern science
fiction texts from the 20th and 21st
century
and i looked at seven of these i mean i
read lots more but there were only seven
that seemed
to be particularly impactful talking
about colonialism
in very detailed and specific ways in my
analysis what i did is a close reading
of all these sources
and close reading for thinking about
particular kinds of questions
so one of the questions i was very
interested in is how do supporters of
colonialism
people to like leave their homes and go
into these foreign spaces
which are typically very hostile
um and also are there sort of common
lines of argument that emerge
from their efforts to persuade people to
do this
and so through historical comparison by
looking at early modern texts
um and modern uh
literature about colonization i was
interested to see whether there are
similarities and differences in the
lines of arguments that we find
and what might account for these
similarities and differences so i'm
going to talk a little bit about
specifically the last question in the
discussion part
of my presentation so let's let's talk
let's start with the early modern uh
proto-colonial period
so typically you know when people think
about colonization um they typically
think of colonization as something that
people
really wanted to do um either because
there's some instinctual
uh nature within humans that wants to go
out and explore places
or because they thought it was like some
great um
i don't know escape from their
socio-economic conditions or whatever
but in fact uh it was really hard to
persuade people
um in to go to go to colonize or
to be part of this sort of colonial
project and we see this time and time
again when you look at these very early
proto-colonial tracks
um so for example um john white's
planner's plea which is written in 1630
he is sort of emblematic of the kinds of
things that you read
or that or that these folks that are
writing these kinds of tracks right
so he writes in this some men are
content to remove from their dwellings
and leave their beloved country and
friends
let no man conceive that we shall find
over many of that humor
we english are known too well to the
world to love the smoke of our own
chimneys
so well that hopes of great advantages
are not likely to draw
many of us from home so many of the the
folks that write these tracks say
it's really hard to get people to leave
so then what i was really interested in
is the arguments that they then made to
try to get
people to to buy into the colonial
project and be participants in it
the kind of literature that emerged so
this this actually emerges as a genre of
literature during this period called
what's called promotional literature
and typically what happened during this
period is that some folks
would go over and they would you know be
part of one of these fortress
colonies um that were meant to sort of
stake things out and maybe
make a a military foothold to make a
claim
and then they would come back and they
would say very nasty things about
um being in the colony and how one how
not really wonderful it was
so a lot of promotional literature was
sort of aimed at
um addressing these brutes as they were
called
um where people were just sort of uh
talking badly about the colonial
experience
um so as a definition of this genre
one of one historian writes the
principal purposes of promotional
literature
was to combat the flood of slander and
malicious gossip about the colonies
of which almost every important writer
complains
so we have this promotional literature
then that's meant sort of as a
rhetorical tool
to get people to think positively about
the comments
so one of the things i was interested in
is well okay you know what kind of
rhetoric do we find
in these docu in these this literature
and what i've what i found is that
typically in the early modern period we
have what's called reassurance rhetoric
um there's a there's a argument
theoretician named uh behind pearlman
who talks about dissociative argument um
dissociative argument is essentially
argument where
um you say well this is what they're
saying but what really is happening is
this so it's a dissociation
of the imagined and the real so a lot of
argument
in this vein is about trying to correct
sort of uh incorrect or inappropriate
descriptions of the risk in the colonial
space
so there were lots of different kinds of
risks that these writers talk about in
promotional literature
one of them of course is indigenous
people so here's an example
of a colonist who went
to virginia his name is ralph lane and
he came back and he wrote a very
a very uh scathing negative uh
description of the experience that he
had
so he writes about the indigenous people
there wanted no store of mischievous
practices among them
the indigenous people of roanoke in the
dead of night they would have descent my
house and put fire in the reeds
that myself would have come running out
and of a sudden amazed in my night shirt
without arms meaning weapons upon an
instant whereof
they would have knocked out my brains so
lane is describing his fear
that they were going that the that the
native americans of the roanoke
um were going to essentially slaughter
all the colonists
and that he would be a main victim and
that they were going to sort of set fire
to his house and then and then
beat his brains out when he ran out um
of course then
the promoters of this colony um
needed to have some way of responding to
these sort of
uh negative impressions that they were
giving about the colony
um so another piece was written soon
after
harriet's i mean soon after the one we
just read by thomas harriet
which is known as the brief and true
report written in 1587
and this report harriet tries to
um rehabilitate people's
beliefs about native americans
suggesting that you know the slanderous
accounts are incorrect
and really there's a very different way
that we should think about the native
americans
so he writes arrested that i speak a
word or two of the natural inhabitants
their natures and manners as that you
may know
how that they in respect to troubling
are inhabiting and planting
are not to be feared but that they shall
have caused to both fear
and love us that she'll inhabit with
them so he was really trying to change
everybody's mind
about these stories that they were
hearing about the dangers of the native
americans
um i'm not going to offer all the
evidence here but what i can tell you is
that
he makes a series of arguments one based
on the fact that their militaries are
not very big
and also that the weapons that they have
are much cruder than the english
and therefore they're not really much of
a threat militarily speaking
he also he also makes a sort of
technological argument
arguing that the native americans were
so amazed by their technologies
that they in some ways thought that they
were they were to be respected and
worshiped
um because their god was so superior and
and that they would sort of fall in line
um just out of sheer uh i don't know
a belief that the technology was
superior so that they would just
they would just sort of go along with
whatever the english believed in
um there were other hazards and risks of
course outside of
native peoples um there was a lot of
discussion in these
in these tracks about hazardous fauna
um in the planters plea for example um
white talks a lot about
snakes uh people were really afraid of
these snakes they were bigger than the
ones in england
so he had to say say a few words about
the fact that no one really ever sees
them and the more people that go the
less snakes they'll be
so the idea here is to sort of dismiss
out of hand
the dangers of these snakes their
existence and um
the fact that they're gonna really have
a problem with the colonists
the other thing are mosquitoes um so
england didn't really have mosquitoes
but of course north america was plagued
by them
especially in the places that that these
colonies were were set down
um so one of the things they had to say
is look the mosquitoes aren't that bad
right you can wear long sleeves you can
go in doors you can
set fires and you know frankly if you
live there after a while you don't even
notice them
so these are some strategies that they
they had to sort of reassure
um potential colonists that these
problems weren't really that serious
problems
now another risk that um people in the
early modern period took very seriously
was the effect of the food and climate
and drink on the bodies
of the colonists so this is a very big
deal at this period
um and now of course as well so
um william bradford when he talks about
the history of the plymouth
plantation he talks in great detail
about the arguments that
the group of calvinists that that joined
him in plymouth
had over the kinds of problems that they
were going to face
and why they should or shouldn't
colonize or decide to build to have a
colony
in north america one of these debates is
is based squarely around the conditions
and the effects of the conditions on the
bodies
of the members of this congregation so
for there in north america
they should be liable to famine and
nakedness and the want in a manner of
all things
the change of air diet and drinking of
the water should infect their bodies
with sore sickness and grievous diseases
so this is one of the arguments made
against
uh setting up a colony in north america
to sort of counter that we have
we have um tracks like john brayton's a
brief and true relation
um so bertin essentially was traveling
around martha's vineyard
and he comes back and he and he says a
few words about the food and the drink
and how it affected
the folks that were in his particular
expedition
we found our health and strength all the
while we remained there so renewed
and increased as notwithstanding our
diet and lodging was none of the best
yet none of our company felt the least
grudging or inclination to any disease
or sickness
but we're much fatter in better health
than we went out of england
so there are a lot of instances in these
tracks where they will talk about how
the food and the drink
and everything else actually made the
the colonists healthier
and didn't have the negative impacts on
the health that was brooded by some of
these other
um accounts of of the new world
um so um i'm going to switch gears now
so i've been talking about north america
and the colonial experience there
so there were some some similarities and
differences obviously between north
america and mars
um one of the differences of course is
there to our knowledge there are no
indigenous habitants of mars we have not
found life there
yet um so and and the other thing is
that no humans have ever been there
so we can't have the same kinds of
accounts um
and and brutes of the experience of
being on mars because no one's ever
done it also though there is a
similarity because there are some
climatic hazards on mars
that we don't share in our own um in our
own earth
now of course the climactic hazards are
very different than the one the climatic
hazards are very different than the ones
that you experience
in north america first of all the
average temperature is much colder on
mars
uh than it is on earth this is not
something there are temperature problems
um that colonists had to deal with but
not to this extreme
um oxygen so we never had to worry about
oxygen
um when when setting up colonies in
north america or other places on earth
um and of course there's problems of
radiation
there's a lot more radiation on it that
that's
given on a daily basis on mars than
there is on earth so there are
definitely risks
obviously environmental risks to talk
about when we talk about mars
um so because there are no
uh there's not the same kind of
uh writing about colonization
for mars that there was for north
america uh we have to turn to a new
source and so one of the sources that we
have
is science fiction so um
science fiction is great because even
though there's not there hasn't been a
human experience on mars
science fiction writers imagine what it
would be like to set up a colony at
march and imagine what would be like
to be the humans that are colonizing and
what their experience would be like
um what's also very interesting is that
science fiction writers
like like isaac asimov and arthur c
clarke and ray bradbury um were very
supportive of the notion of astral
colonialism
um even ray bradbury who who does
write very critically about colonialism
for example in the martian chronicles
has other writings where he is sort of
very sanguine about
this idea of astro colonialism so for
example for the 1964 world fair
um he wrote a particular script
for this journey through um america
um in which in the final part of the
script he writes
build pyramids of men and fire toward
landfalls on the moon
and bright new independence days looking
back from sprays to see our birthplace
earth
the old wilderness dwindles as the human
race reaches for eternity
survival and immortality in the next
billion years
man god made manifest goes in search of
himself
the great outpour of all nations which
crushed the buffalo grass
and reach the end of one frontier now
binds great now finds greater challenges
in the star wilderness above um so we
see in this the very language of
colonialism the very language of sort of
the
the westward expansion of the buffalo
grass in
bradbury's comments so it suggests that
he too
um is sort of enamored by
uh the notion of the colonial um the
astral colonialism
of other planets so what we find uh
that's a little bit different in science
fiction writing than in the earlier
colonial tracks
is that the rhetoric here instead of
being reassurance rhetoric
is what i would call inspirational
rhetoric and there are sort of two sorts
one is what i would call
heroic inspirational rhetoric and the
other is utopian inspirational rhetoric
um heroic inspirational rhetoric is
really interesting
because what it does is instead of
trying to reassure
the the readers and and the audience
that life on on in the colonial space
isn't so bad
they actually leverage the challenges
and the struggle for existence within
the colonial space
to make to to um
to make people heroes and by doing that
also valorizing
the process of colonialization and the
people that are going to become
colonialists
so we see this um very obviously
and andy wears the martian which um many
of you probably have seen in the film
or you've read in in the novel form um
in this novel and
in the film of course we have the
protagonist mark watney
um who is a scientist uh he's a botanist
engineer
and he uses his maker skills and his
rational thinking ability
to of course um send off
one disaster for another and by doing
that sort of becomes a hero
by his ability to sort of conquer the
challenges
of mars as a space we also see the same
thing happening in isaac asimov's the
martian way which is written in 1952
and in asimov's novel there's also sort
of a hero
scientist who's an engineer and the idea
is that
that mars is being cut off from water
and they have to solve this problem
um sort of through their own ingenuity
and and i won't
um spoil the plot of this um but what i
can say is
that um what's different a little bit
about the watney
example and this heroic example is that
the hero in the case of the martian way
draws their draws their very ability to
make
and do certain kinds of things from
their
from their existence as colonists in
other words
only martians only someone who lives on
mars and deals with the conditions
can do the kinds of um
techno can do the kinds of technological
things that make survival possible
um so uh isimov asimov writes for
example
we can we can do it and earth men can't
they've got a real world they've got
open sky and food
getting into a ship will challenge them
right we've been living on a ship our
entire lives
breathing packaged air drinking packaged
water we eat the same food and rations
we eat aboard a ship
we get into a ship the same thing we've
known all our lives
so the colonial conditions themselves um
condition the settlers
to actually be able to survive in ways
that folks that are not
martian um can't do so they can sort of
solve problems in ways that earth people
can't solve problems
so now i want to switch a little bit and
talk about inspirational rhetoric
and i call this this argument that of
inspirational rhetoric as as argument
per arduour or argument through
adversity
and what we see here is what's called a
means ends argument
so um in this kind of argument the
the person that the colonist is
submitting themselves or the potential
colonists
is submitting themselves to
extraordinary trials which are the means
and the ends are the extraordinary
benefits that you reap through these
trials
so the idea is that going to mars is
hard but through this hardship
um we get these unique benefits um
and there is a there is a a rich history
of this kind of argument in our own
colonial
experience in our own colonial tracks um
so frederick jackson turner um in his
very famous piece on the frontier
writes it is to the frontier the
american intellect owes its striking
characteristics
that coarseness of strength combined
with the cuteness acquisitive
inquisitiveness and practical that
practical inventive turn of the mind
quick to find expedience and masterful
graphs grasp of material things
our traits are called out elsewhere
because of the existence of the frontier
so the notion is that the frontier in
some ways
um is responsible for the kind of traits
that made america america
that made it great that made it unique
um and so we
but it's only through the trials of the
frontier that you get those kind of
qualities
and we see this very same argument being
made in science fiction texts
a perfect example of this is arthur c
clarke's the red sands of mars
and in this book we have the protagonist
martin gibson is a journalist
and he's sort of writing an expose on
mars he's going to journey to mars and
talk about what colonial life is like
and so forth
and he's really skeptical at first about
about the colonial project right he says
you know look from the point of view of
earth you know
mars is a long way it costs a lot of
money it doesn't offer anything
and the question that we're all asking
is what do we get out of it right
so the whole point of this novel then is
to answer this question what do we get
out of it
and after spending time in the colony um
gibson has this sort of epiphenol
experience and then he becomes a strong
advocate in fact he becomes the
pr person for mars and what he finds is
that he experiences
when he gets in with with the folks on
mars right
um he begins to understand that what
they
gain from being on mars in their
colonial experience
right is this kenai competence and
readiness to take well calculated risks
which and it enabled them not merely to
survive on this heartbreakingly hostile
world
world but to lay the foundations of the
first extraterrestrial culture
so this notion that you know a utopia
or a return to utopia begins to develop
through
existing within the harsh conditions of
mars
another example of utopian rhetoric is
in kim stanley robinson's uh novel read
mars which is part of a
trilogy um so what's interesting is that
in
in robinson's novel there are a hundred
colonists that are the original
colonists of mars
and the whole point of this novel is to
talk about
how they struggle to realize their
utopian
vision for a particular colony and it's
really the struggle itself
um and sort of maintaining a pure space
um for mars which is uh
which is the struggle that if they
succeed will have this sort of utopian
benefits
so one of the main characters writes all
of our says
all of our governments are flawed it's
why history is such a bloody mess
we are now on our own and i for one have
no intention of repeating earth's
mistakes
we are the first martian colonists we
are the scientists it is our job to
think things new
and make them new so the idea is that
mars was really a toblerosa
in which we can build this ideal society
on
and the struggle is not so much the
struggle of existence on mars
but the struggle to keep this a free
space in which
to create this ideal colony or this
ideal utopia
that the martians want so now very
briefly i'm just going to talk about the
the the sort of the the contrast we see
between the rhetoric of early modern
colonialism the rhetoric of science
fiction
and martian colonialism so early modern
promotional rhetoric is devoted to
reassuring potential colonists and
supporters
by dismissing and diminishing the risks
of colonial life right i don't worry
about the serpents don't worry about
mosquitoes
or the indigenous peoples there
everything is going to be fine
inspirational rhetoric however of the
modern science fiction
leverages the risks of colonization to
valorize the colonists and to make a
case for the good consequences
that will arise from the colonial act
right you will become a hero
you will realize utopian visions that
you have on earth
so why why these differences what might
account for it
so in thinking about these different
cases one thing that occurred to me is
that
in our modern context right we have a
real faith
in sort of the techno-scientific
capacity to address
risk in a way that early modern folks
did not
so they had to in fact offer
reassurances why well
because they couldn't really say that
they could solve the problems but now
we have this sort of belief in
technology and belief in the
technological progress
such that we can almost valorize um
these these moments of of
colonialism as a way of showing our
chops of way of showing how we can
solve the problems and make ourselves
heroes by doing so
the other thing that's interesting is
that um in early modern
colonialism in the in the british
context
there's not really a lot of ideal models
um
that can serve as this notion of colony
as utopia
i mean the the scottish colonization and
the irish colonization were
kind of a big bloody mess for the most
part
they didn't really have very much ideal
there wasn't a lot of idealism
associated
with it and there were a lot of um
writings by historians that suggest
that they can't really find this kind of
utopian statements very early in these
proto-colonial periods
but they do find them later and we see
of course historically that these
developed and
smart fiction writers have these as
resources for
making their arguments okay that's all
that i have
um so uh vivek i will turn it back over
you
um for moderation purposes
so thank you so much for listening
all right thank you um
well i'll first open it up to questions
from our
our students yeah natalia
hi uh thanks for the talk um
i was wondering what made you choose the
early american
exploration um rather than i guess like
what i think a lot of people compare
which is like the westward ho
sort of um like frontier
period thank you
natalia so that's a great question so
one thing i want to say is that you know
the reason first of all
kind of um i chose the british
colonialism because i speak english
um and frankly you know i don't have the
chops to read you know spanish texts or
text in other languages but the reason
why i chose um
north american colonialism and not
westward expansionism
is because at that stage so there's an
argument about whether that's really
colonialism in the first place because
america
um is technically a nation and those
lands are part of the nation
although there's a there's a debate over
whether or not and i i tend to come down
on the side that
yes that is a colonial moment as well
the difference is that
i'm looking at proto-colonial moments
right so
in the proto-colonial moment um there's
a there's a lot of uncertainty
um about the the capacity to even
establish a foothold or whether you want
to establish these colonies
or whether you get people to go there i
mean there is some of that of course in
the westward expansion
um but i think there's there's a
stronger analogy with
um mars and the the sort of north
american
um settlement or this the yes
essentially because
um you know these people are really
going out into these unknown spaces
um and they're you know they're they're
sort of uh bases far away
and it's much more i think more like uh
mars causation i hope that answers your
question
thank you
uh kelly thank you yeah thank you for
the talk um i guess i was just wondering
your talk was very much framed from the
perspective of the colonizer
so like when you frame talking about
indigenous peoples you label them as
like
risks or harms or like you just said you
know these people going out into the
unknown where you don't know
what's out there but people do know i
mean there are people living there that
do know what's out there
um and there's always like another side
to that story
um so i guess i wonder how like why
and not why not
talk about some of the harms that have
happened in the process and i'm sure in
the mars case maybe it's not that there
are people there but that there are
people harmed in this process of
thinking about a single
framework for utopia that doesn't
include everyone
and kind of how even in your talk
continuing to label these people as like
harms or risks perpetuates that
violence kind of thank you
um kelly for that question so what i
want to say to everyone is this is part
of a larger project
so i'm just starting it and my first
chapter happened to be on this
um but i will have a later chapter that
is about
um sort of anti-colonial arguments right
so there will be a whole chapter that
i'm going to dedicate
to those questions specifically um but
the other thing that i would say kelly
is that what's what i find interesting
is that people in the humanities have
done a lot of work on the colonized
but they have done very little work on
the colonizers um
so to me as a as a rhetorician that's
interested in argument
from whatever from whoever's perspective
it's interesting to me that no one
really has written much about
the colonial arguments the arguments of
the colonizers and why
you would want to colonize and how do
you get people to go there so these are
i think spaces that are that's
underexplored
um which is why i decided to explore
them in the first place
um the other thing i would say about
indigenous people um
my project is is about thinking about
how they're
imagining these these groups and how
they're talking about it right
so because i'm writing because i'm
analyzing the argument from their
perspective
that's how they're talking about it so
um i'm not trying to
perpetuate violence i'm just trying to
open up a discussion about this is how
they were seen
this is how they were thought of by this
group right
and then of course this can be critiqued
in a thousand ways but it's them i think
it's valuable in the first place to know
what kind of language what kind of um
place that these indigenous peoples had
in their arguments how they thought
about them how they argued about them
right
does that make sense so it's not that i
it's not that my intention is to ignore
um the opposite position um
but that i'm taking i'm i'm looking at
this from one particular lens in this
chapter
but later chapters you know then we can
swing the lens and look at it from a
different perspective
um yeah oh go ahead sorry carol i'm just
going to say yeah i i
i that makes a lot of sense and i think
you're totally right that like
looking at it from that perspective is
helpful i just think maybe
when talking about it it's good to kind
of acknowledge that because i think it
can still be traumatic for people to
like see those images and hear that
rhetoric
and so maybe just acknowledging that is
worthwhile
oh yeah i mean this is certainly
traumatic um
um especially because the more you read
these you more you see the trauma that
happens right
because in these tracks they talk about
what they did
and what happened and they're very
traumatic yeah
but i think it's important to expose
that trauma and to expose those
perspectives right
as part of what i call what rhetoricians
called disorder
which is seeing different different
sides of a particular issue
or perspective um
so i wanted to just follow up on on
those two questions as well
um you know as because i know that there
are some of us here who are descended
from people who were colonized
um and for whom that that trauma is very
real and continual and and
transgenerational
um and i guess um from
from the standpoint that you're talking
about um
you know focusing on the rhetoric that
the rhetoric that was used to encourage
colonization from the side of the
colonizers
um i guess i would urge you to
to um to think about
the the underlying there's an
underlying rhetorical move right
um that is that the united states
is terra nullis right that that the
united states is not
occupied right or north america or
you know those lands between the pacific
and the atlantic
because i'm not going to call them that
yet
so
for for this territory to be considered
terra nullis in other words unoccupied
territory
there's a really deep rhetorical move
that's being made that's essentially
um you know the rhetoric and and the
technology of race
right which renders the the
indigenous inhabitants as part of the
landscape
rather than as human beings occupying
the
the land for generations and so
you know there's that i think that's
where the difference between
talking about north america and talking
about mars is so
apparent because
if if you make that comparison without
acknowledging that um
in the same way that that mars is being
considered
as colonizable right
um because it's empty
that's essentially the argument that was
made about north america
and that that argument was was one that
entailed violence you know and enabled
it
right so um i guess that's
that's what i would urge you to think
about um and also
to think about the colonial moment not
as
the early colonial moment right um
where the colonial moment ends as
as you were mentioning when the the
colonizers break off from the home
country
but to think about the fact that settler
colonialism was a continual process
and so even if the east coast
of of this region
was settled by colonists who had broken
off from britain
they were still in a pre-colonial or
proto-colonial
relationship to the rest of the the
country
right yeah i mean i it's interesting
because i think that
that the notion of terra nola's is a
little bit fraught
on the one hand um there is sort of
there are sort of property arguments
about you know land that's available but
i think that
what these tracks show is that they are
painfully aware that these lands are
people
um and that that's a risk um and they're
real people there they are re
they are like them they are and that
they can fight and that they
are a risk so i i don't i wouldn't say
that that they
they're going into this thinking like oh
nobody's there like i think they're very
painfully aware and that it's part of
their the fact that they have to write
things like oh it's fine you know there
are people there but they're not gonna
you know try to to harm us if we live
there so i mean i think that
that i'm not sure that that's
necessarily true of the rhetoric of that
of that of that situation um
but it but it is interesting because
there there and of course
there's so much going on in in this
period
like you know the fact that um
the the spanish and the portuguese have
essentially had the world divided
between them
um but with the blessing of the catholic
church so
um technically this isn't even a space
where the the british are allowed to go
um but after the the you know great
battle of the spanish armada
and the the the english winning that
battle and they feel a little bit more
okay with you know setting up
settlements in places
i mean it's very it's a very complicated
story
um but i don't want to diminish i don't
want to diminish in any way the violence
that would that were done to the native
peoples and and continue to be done
right so this notion
that you mentioned um what's and it's
called in
in the literature neocolonialism right
this notion that colonialism keeps going
and going and going like you can't
escape it
um even after the fact um it still is
perpetuated within the system with
movies and tv
and all kinds of media um so i'm not i'm
not
negating any of that but i will say that
you know
i am taking a particular lens and
perspective to look at this
through the perspective of the
colonizers and how they're trying to get
people to go to that space
um i think it is important to think
about the difference between mars
and north america especially with the
notion of
indigenous persons or indigenous life
there
because so far as we know there we have
not found life on mars yet
um and so that that some of the issues
that
um are very present in discussion of
colonialism
on earth um maybe either absent or
different
in thinking about the colonialism of
mars and and
that the the presence of sentient
people who would be colonized um or
destroyed or you know what whatever
is a different question on mars so yeah
so thank you for that feedback in other
words thank you
um there's some questions actually that
are in the q a
um all right from jason lynch what do
you see
as the relationship between colonialism
and
capitalism relatedly have you read or
watched the expanse and what are your
thoughts on its politics of colonialism
exploitation and labor
um and then there's a addition to that
do you see any differences
between imagining of mars colonization
versus
other interplanetary and interstellar
notions of colonization
thank you those are great are you seeing
the qa bar as well
i am thank you so uh yes i see that
that's at the top
by jason thank you jason for your
question um yes
uh it's it's interesting because
colonization and capitalism
are are very very much intertwined but
in ways that we don't always expect
um so what i found interesting is that
many of the early efforts of of the
english
to set up colonies were actually
business ventures
um and the the thing is that
in the very early so the very early
colonial efforts especially in
newfoundland which is where the english
first went
around 1495 which is very early right a
couple years after
um columbus um and initially
um the the folks that went there like
cabot
and others um when they went
they couldn't get any they had to like
essentially
sell people a story like we're gonna
find the northwest passage i mean the
northwest passage so i want to
i don't i know this has really been a
long time since you know
in high school history or whatever that
you've talked about that northwest
passage
but i can't emphasize enough how
important the idea of the northwest
passage was
because at the at this point um trade
and
was was really built around stuff coming
from the east
spices silks all these kinds of things
and the way that it came into the west
into europe was
through the middle east and because of
religious differences
um there was some tensions there about
you know dealing with
um non-christian folks um and also there
was a
problem of prices right so by the time
silk
went from china and ended up in a port
on the mediterranean that you could
actually
go and get it from um it was really
really expensive
so for these um i i really
like to call them entrepreneurs because
cabot
in particular and some of the early
folks were entrepreneurs like they were
saying like if we find this passage
we are going to be rich beyond our
wildest dreams because we're going to be
able to bring spices
and silks and there'll be no middleman
we're going to get all the
we're going to get all the the benefit
we could charge lower prices
you know this is going to be great so
the idea is that
and and what's interesting about north
america is
when the spanish went into the south um
they found a lot of gold and resources
um the the british and some other folks
thought that they would find the same in
the north and they didn't
and so for a long time north america was
just not
not really that important because
frankly there were they weren't finding
the northwest passage and they weren't
finding any gold
so um if you look at the early
i mean it was very it was it was kind of
bad business and a lot of a lot of the
early colonial efforts just failed
because they couldn't they couldn't show
profit they couldn't make a buck
and in fact the only thing that kind of
saved north america
i mean looking at it from the from the
business perspective um is sassafras
um because sassafras was in high demand
in england
it was all over north america it was
very cheap to transport
and you could make a book off of it so
it's it's strange how like fish and
sassafras were things
that kept people kind of interested in
going to north america when in fact
um for the most part it was really kind
of seen as a bad business deal
so i know that's a really long that's a
really long answer to your question but
i hope it shows like how integral sort
of capitalism
is to thinking about even
the possibility of colonization because
it was a huge
risk it was a huge financial risk and
without reward people were not willing
to do it
which again is why in the pro
proto-colonial period there's a lot of
interesting rhetoric and arguments about
the economics of it
okay sorry that's a long that's a long
answer but
i'll go to go to another question um
are there any questions on the on the
screen before i go back to the q a
okay um so
let me see i i took one from q a and i'm
going to take one from chat now
this is from ricardo perez rhetoric is a
fascinating exploratory discipline the
first colonizers to america were mainly
convicts searching for
liberty from imprisonment that was a
major motivational factor enabling the
exploration
there was also a myth of richness that
may have been instrumental
in the genesis of the process
so oh and then oh there is a question at
the
um at the bottom and why was avatar not
considered in your rhetoric exposition
thank you um avatar is great it's a
perfect example
of like multinationals coming into a
pristine environment and destroying it
um i didn't i didn't use it because it's
not mars um
all the all of the science fiction i
looked at was specifically about
mars and mars colonization um
so all of the novels i read were
squarely about that
um just because it was my topic area not
because i'm not interested in avatar and
other
examples like the expanse and because
there's so much out there
um so thank you for that question but
that's that's really i was trying to
focus on mars
um from muhammad reza nasiri in the q a
thank you for the interesting talk two
questions if you have time for both
first it's interesting that here here
when we focus on mars colonization
we read sorry this is jumping over my
page the way that i've got it
it's interesting that when we focus on
mars colonization
we read those sci-fi works literally but
at the same time many of those sci-fi
novels and films have been
making the case for american
neocolonialism
in an allegorical way how do you deal
with this kind of dialectic between
allegory and literal in such sci-fi
works
yeah i mean i think um what's
interesting is that these works and
we may not be thinking about this but
these works really do
um circulate within the american public
and prime
the american public to think about
colonization in particular ways to
valorize it
and to imagine it in particular ways so
i think that these
that these instruments i mean nasa knows
this i mean
the martian was sponsored by nasa was
vetted by nasa writers
i mean by folks at nasa so i mean they
realize that this is a way
to help shape the story or the frame
um of colonization of mars um and i
don't know if you guys watch the
national geographic
mars series that's a great series um all
of these theories are really designed
specifically to make particular kinds of
arguments
about what it's going to be like why
we're doing this
um it's very important to is sort of
like
a prelude to actually doing it right you
have to prepare the audience
to to see this in a particular way
before then they're
willing to like open the checkbook of
the national government and spend money
on these things
and spend their lives going there if
they do
okay i'm going to go to kenneth alba and
then i'll come back to hamid reza to
your second question um i wonder if you
could speak to the way that hard science
fiction
like red mars comes bundled with
epistemological claims that end up
supporting
ideological claims i really like
really like the proto-colonial texts you
brought up
but the comparison that always jumps to
mind for me
is the uh robinson day
robinson aide robinson crusoe
when where the focus on accounting and
details and so forth
has certain truth claims grounded
could you speak to speak a bit to
how genre specificity and epistemology
interact in these kinds of
neocolonialist texts
wow that's a very rich question so
there's a lot there to talk about
um it's interesting robinson caruso
there are a number of
films and there's one novel that's an
amazing it's right it's called
it's called robinson crusoe on mars it's
a great novel um
by i think his name is rex morgan he's
an australian writer
uh or british writer alfred
australian writer that writes goes to
britain and writes about this in britain
um but yeah the robinson a does appear
in
in different instances um in discussions
about mars and mars colonization
particularly the notion of like the
marooned like if you think about andy
where's the martian like this notion of
the marooned
um scientist or the marooned explorer on
mars
so you do have that as sort of a trope
that goes through some of the literature
um but i this notion of hard science
fiction i think is very important
because
um in my estimation the more
real the science fiction is um
the more real that it seems that it's
true
so one of the things about the martian
that i find really kind of compelling as
an example
is in the movie it seems like this is
real like people are already on mars
like they're really doing this
they could really survive so the realism
of it i think
supports um the supports the premise
that we could do this or we have done
this or we can do this
um so i think that the genre matters
like if it's all
sort of you know really super fictional
and and
and um not quite so true to life
um i think it it's harder to make the
case that this is true or this can
happen or we should do this
so i think like where's novel in this
and robinson
you read that you believe that people
are there you believe that you could do
this
and that this is how it's to go it's
going to unfold um so i think the re
the the hard science fiction is
extremely important genre in thinking
about
um arguments for mars conversation
okay great um i'm going to
let me see i'll come back to hamid reza
um
the second question um also i'm curious
whether you're considering making
comparisons between the rhetoric used
for the case of israel and the discourse
arguing
that life actually originated on mars
and then transferred to earth the
argument of
original home for colonialism
interesting so actually um
i had been thinking about israel but not
in that sense like the notion of like
life starting on mars and then coming to
earth um i really haven't thought about
that so that's a great angle
and thank you for that but i have been
thinking about
um colonization in different spaces and
so this notion of setting up
um uh kibbutz's
as sort of being also um
as a way of thinking about colonization
um is that colonization
if so why or why not or you know what
what is this sort of language what are
the arguments
um for these kinds of settlements um i
think
i i've looked into it a little bit not a
lot but i was kind of intrigued by this
notion of thinking about whether there
might be some analogs there
that would be useful to help me think
about colonial arguments and colonial
moments
okay um ally
has a question do you want to um do you
want me to take the question from the
chat or would you like to
oh i i didn't drop it in the chat sorry
um i can i can just say it um
i was also really interested in your
reading of kim stanley robinson's
red mars series um i really wanted to
ask you about
your reading of it as utopian and heroic
which is
really interesting to me especially with
the overtones of like the martian
exceptionalism and the people on mars
are going to achieve
x y and z um and especially just with
like the
the how how the fault lines show in that
i was wondering how the how that
exceptionalism plays into
the narrative of colonization
if that makes sense i can yeah yeah so
like this notion that like we are an
exceptional people therefore
you know we have the right to colonize
here or it is our destiny to colonize
here sort of thing
or the sense that uh people who
are on mars are um the
i believe the quote you used was uh we
won't make earth's mistakes or something
along those lines
um that kind of thinking yeah i mean
um so it's really interesting because uh
in the beginning of robinson's book you
have a hundred colonists right
and they train in antarctica and they're
supposed to give like reasons why they
want to go to mars
and most of this is supposed to be like
oh well i'm really interested in this
science or we could do this thing
but when they all get on the spaceship
and they're away from earth they're all
like
screw it the reason we want to go to
mars is we want to build a new society
because we're tired of earth in the way
that
you know earth society and capitalism
and everything's messed up and we're
going to start
sort of a really a new utopic world on
mars
um and of course what's interesting
about the novel is that
um it's a very about half of the novel
the first half
they're able to do this and they're
they're you know they've created this
place called underhill
um and they've they've started to um
make their utopian ideas come true in
some small ways and they're thinking
and planning how to do it and then they
find gold on mars
and the minute gold is found on mars all
the transnationals show up and
all of a sudden it's just like earth
again right um and so there's this
notion of
there's this constant tension between
like and then they have to go
underground and they become
revolutionaries i don't want to
rule the whole plot of the novels but
but i i think there is this notion that
you know their ideas are pure
um and correct and and that all
everything that earth stands for with
capitalism
and and big government right
um and not allowing like small
self-government or allowing people to
form their own groups and
and do have their own lives i mean i
think kim stanley robinson is a
libertarian so
much of the libertarian thinking kind of
comes out in his novels
um so i don't know if i'm answering your
question ally
um uh but i think there is this notion
that that this is the right way to think
about how the world should be um
which is essentially an
anti-capitalistic perspective
but things are more egalitarian
thank you wait natalia
had her hand up a moment ago
yeah um so i'm i work in exoplanets
and um i have also seen that
um in the space community at mit and
aero astro as well there's been a big
move
um in changing the language of how we
talk about
humans going to the moon
to mars or like in the very distant
future exoplanets
and it's becoming very unpopular
to say colonize or we're trying to
actively tell others like maybe we
shouldn't say colonize maybe we should
say
explore or visit um
and rethinking it like as scientists
and like nasa decadal surveys are
starting to
like include that in thinking about the
next 10 years and so
um i'm really curious about this section
in your project on anti-colonial
thinking and what that's going to look
like
thank you natalia i hope um maybe we can
connect because i'd be really interested
in talking to you a little bit about
the kinds of language changes that
you're seeing in the kinds of documents
that i might be able to look at to talk
about this because i think that's
fascinating
that that you know because if you look
at nasa's stuff
it's pretty colonial focused at least
during the periods i've been looking at
so it's interesting that they've kind of
caught
on that this might not be the best
framing for this
and they might want to think
rhetorically about changing the way that
they talk about
um their their exhibition
they're traveling to exoplanets and mars
and other spaces
um i'm trying to think okay i'm hoping
i'm not losing the threat of your
question
um could you just repeat the last part
that you said because i think i lost
that thread
yeah i was curious if you could give
like a brief outline or like teaser like
what um what the path is going to be for
like the anti-colonialist
parts of your project so it is
interesting because there are
so i mentioned ray bradbury earlier um
the martian chronicles is actually
science fiction that's very anti is is
sort of focused towards anti-colonialism
um because what he talks about is how
one you know like
um so the the space travelers go to
earth
the the martians aren't too excited
about having them there like they don't
think it's great
and they end up like trying to eliminate
them until of course all the martians
die of a disease that's brought from
earth right which is
um analogic to the smallpox uh
outbreak uh in the united states after
european settlers got here
so we see a lot of this sort of like
he's reminding us of
um all of the the atrocities essentially
um that occurred um when uh
uh when they colonized north america
right so these are very much present in
bradbury's work
which is interesting given the sort of
juxtaposition that it has with that
quote that i showed you earlier
so there's sort of like maybe a fraught
um
relationship for him about about this
moment about going to mars
the other thing there is a very
interesting environmental argument where
um you know humans go to mars and they
trash it
so they're throwing junk in the canal
and they're essentially doing the same
thing to this planet that they did to
earth
right so this notion that humans aren't
going to change and they're just going
to get this new
beautiful planet and they're going to
destroy it and i think kim stanley
robinson also
talks he there's a there's a there's a
lot of discussion about terraforming
which is a very central part of his
novel um and so terraforming is going to
be an interesting
um way of thinking about colonialism
because it's like uber colonialism
you're not only like
showing up in a place you're just
completely transforming it so that you
can live there
right which you know we've done that in
a number of ways
on earth but this is like taking it to
the next level where you're just totally
taking this ecology of a planet and
completely changing it
so it suits your own needs right so
there's that issue
um there's also issues of race there's
issues uh
especially was so um i don't know if you
guys know gil scott herron
but he has this really great song called
whities on the moon right
where he talks about how essentially you
know we could be using the money for
space projects for social projects on
earth
um why do we do that um there's also the
same environmental arguments about
why don't we use the money that we could
be exploring mars to
work on climate change on earth right
why why don't we worry about our own
planet
and not worry about going living on
other planets um but sort of
the racial inequities also come out in
other kinds of stories um
about questions of like so they're
they're like i think it's philip k
dick where he talks a lot about like
these people go to the moon and they
work as miners like who are these miners
like while they end up being people that
were poor on earth that they could just
sort of exploit and send to mars which
is a terrible environment
to extract resources and then bring them
back to earth for everybody else who's
rich
so there's there's a lot of this this
sort of notion that colonialism is going
to be
um they're going to colonize they're
going to just they're it's just going to
be extractive of resources
you're going to have the same folks on
earth that are taking risks in labor to
take those risks on mars
and on other planets you also see this
in the expanse right where
um the folks that are working um and i
can't
i can't recall the name right now the
folks that work on the outer rim and the
asteroids
are all like sort of poor um
folks that are you know their rights are
trampled on and they're just sort of
exploited for their labor in these very
dangerous spaces
so we see those so those are like that's
a preview
of the kind of things that i'd like to
talk about um and i'd be interested
to hear from anyone else if there are
other kinds of issues
that i think are worth talking about um
with respect and and of course
afrofuturism um if we want to talk about
race and space
that's something also that's important
to talk about and think about
thanks i'm going to go back to the q a
um
let's see where was i um from
anonymous attendee have you read and do
you have uh thoughts on
a memory called empire often noted as an
anti-imperial space opera thank you
i have not read them so um thank you so
much for bringing to my attention i just
wrote it down i've got a little tablet
here of writing down stuff people are
asking
and saying uh so a memory called empire
um
i am going to explore that thank you for
the source
i've always the more i can get the more
i can look at the better i
the happier i am the better i feel
um next from yen ue
have you read hao jin fang's
vagabond and if so what are your
thoughts on whether there is a
difference
in the ideas of colonization in this
chinese science fiction text
compared to the english texts that you
use
so um i have not i have not read
vagabond i've heard about it
um there's also another text whose name
escapes me right now but i think is by a
chinese author
and the whole um premise of the story
is that essentially earth
sends and receives signals from an
extraterrestrial life form
um and then they realize oh my god if
someone
can send and receive these signals it's
very likely that they're gonna like
come to us and that we're gonna be
colonized
so there's about oh yeah yes thank you
the three body problem thank you so much
um the name of the novel is a three body
problem um or
and so the idea is that you know what if
what if we should maybe not be sending
all these messages out of space because
we could be the next
place to get colonized by some uh
by some some folks out there that have
more technology than we do
um so that's a very interesting sort of
alternative perspective
but of course you know there are the
sci-fi five flicks from the
the 50s and 60s where you know uh
extraterrestrials come to earth
um and like how to serve man right as a
menu and not
uh and not a doctrine about how to help
men
so anyway uh i think that was the day
they are stood still but
but there are lots of there are lots of
examples like that where you have films
about
earth being colonized but i think the
chinese writers
that that particular series i think is
very interesting the three-body problem
all right thanks um i've been going to
the
list a lot are there um are there other
graduate students or anyone else on
screen who wants to
ask a question um
okay i'm gonna go back to the list then
and then i have one other question but i
i'll
i'll go through um a couple more um
this is from ricardo again what factor
commands the
massive commitment of national resources
to explore a hostile environment
and not the ocean yeah
interesting that's a great question um
factor of course is um international one
factor
is international prestige so one of the
chapters i'm going to be devoting my
into my book on is about the politics of
of
you know space research in in mars
colonization
um because think of if you think about
it um there's a really famous speech by
kennedy
um it's called his moon speech which is
given at rice university and i think
1961 or 63.
um and in the speech he said he
essentially says and this is the
per arguable argument i was talking
about my talk of argument from
difficulty he says
we go to the moon not because it's easy
but because it's hard
and the idea is that if because it's
hard if you can
show that you can do it then you're
better than everyone else
so essentially it's a way of you know
having national prestige
um and it's worth putting a lot of money
into
endeavors that show your national
prestige
so if you think about mars and
especially mars in the last like two
months
um china the united states and the
united arab emirates have all sent
um either probes or landers or all of
the above to mars
and the notion is that there is a new in
my estimation a new space race on
india china the united states the
european union
everyone is competing for these uh for
reaching these extraterrestrial spaces
and living on them
um so i think that this is going to be
heating up in the way that it was
heating up
uh in the 1960s and and and kennedy's
speech i think is very evocative of
what i see happening now so why would we
spend the resources
um because if we don't we're gonna be
second
and um we can't have national pride
uh of place so i think that that might
be one reason why we will do
you've been it uh uh
good about answering a lot of questions
i i love these are great questions
so i'm gonna take one more from the q a
and then then
um i have one one last kind of follow-up
um and this is well there are a couple
of recommendations
um a couple of scholarly recommendations
for following up on some of the earlier
comments
mark jerning's racial world making
the power of popular fiction uh
and john ryder's colonialism and the
emergence
of science fiction and then in the other
list there's a reference to parable of
the sower
and have you read parable of the sower
and thought about the rhetoric
for dispersing through the cosmos like
seed on the wind
that's a very common trope actually um
isaac asimov
talks a lot about this um he talks a lot
about us as the footloose vikings of the
future
um interstellar vikings that is so we
get in our long ships and we go out and
we spread the spread humanity throughout
the universe
um and a lot of the argument there is
well you know you have all these blank
spaces
and what we want to do is we want to
create awareness
of these spaces and you can't have
awareness without people so therefore
we'll bring people there
um it kind of goes back to vivec your
your notion of tara newlas
um so there is this idea that well if if
if nothing's there
it's not very valuable but if people are
there we can make value of it
we can make it exist in a way that it
doesn't exist if there aren't people
there
so um there's some very interesting
arguments definitely this this footloose
viking of the future is
arthur c clark asimov all those guys
talk about this
and a lot
thanks so uh what i wanted to
just circle back to um
and i think i i was still
kind of um trying to articulate this but
um it goes back to i guess the
question i asked about whether or what
kind of rhetorical moves are
being made to
to uh represent certain spaces
around the globe as colonizable by
europeans
in other words what is necessary um
you know and and this is why you know i
think that that the kind of
um early articulations of race and
racial difference and the kind of
emergence of racial science
um that you know in a sense those are
those are the rhetorical um
the repositories of the rhetorical moves
that are being made
to render um
to render certain spaces inhabited by
non-european people um considered
like fair game right and so i guess that
that's
that's part of what i was getting about
getting at earlier
and whether you know whether you can
sort of talk about the tracts um without
talking about a kind of
underlying set of assumptions about
colonized
colon colonizability um
that that maybe don't appear in the
tracks because they're already
sort of settled through other kinds of
rhetorics of
civilization of racial superiority
of you know christian religion in
relation to other religions
um so i'm just interested to to hear a
bit um
about that before we close out yeah
thank you and it and this is going to
send me
back deep into history if you don't if
you if you'll bear with me for a second
um so yes there are very formal
arguments about this
um and what some people may be surprised
to know is that
uh particularly the spanish
were very concerned i mean initially
they were fine with whatever was
happening but then they got really
concerned about it
um and they actually had a series of
debates about
whether that this was even appropriate
and
by looking at those debates you can see
sort of one of the bases of
argumentation and it
has a has a history that goes beyond um
uh even even the the 1492 journey of
columbus
um essentially so in order for a place
to be
considered um colonizable or like you
know that you can
claim as uh property right
so the word the appropriate word is
dominion
so place that you can go and claim
dominion over right
um there were a couple of things so one
um is that that place that space cannot
be
occupied by a christian king so
christianity comes into it right there
has to be
there if there's a christian king there
it's a no-go
you can't just claim dominion over that
um
the second thing is there were lots of
debates over um
whether or not the persons in that space
were civilized
so this goes all the way back to
aristotle and if you if you look
at the debates over um these spaces
there are certain criteria you have to
meet to be considered civilized
you have to have a language you had to
have a written language
you had to have um a social structure
um that was that was obvious like a
hierarchical structure with like
kings and whatever um also you could
make a case for civilization
based on um buildings
um so like if you had a town and things
were laid out your temples and stuff
so one of the challenges was you know
some people that were against
um these these early colonial pushes
especially by the spanish are like look
they have written language they have
towns they have kings
like you know you you can't claim that
these people don't have
they're not civilized because they
actually do have all these things
um there are other parts of the doctrine
though like
cannibalism so if you were a
cannibalistic society you could not be
considered civilized
right because that is the most sort of
unsimple thing you could do is to eat
other people
um so a lot of the sort of false
arguments about cannibalism amongst
certain um groups of of indigenous
peoples
were all aimed at suggesting that
they're not civilized right because they
couldn't
make an argument on these other grounds
so so there was
there those were one that's one set of
arguments so you had the sort of like
the legal arguments about the christian
king the arguments about whether the
people are civilized
and then there was a third set of
arguments um
that were that were there were actually
sort of like economic arguments
um so a lot of a lot of folks that were
doing colonization were trying to find a
middle way
where they were saying like okay we
recognize your civilized we recognize
your
your dominion to some degree over these
places that you're in
but what we see is that there are all
these uncultivated spaces
and so what we're suggesting is that if
a space isn't cultivated
like there's not fields there's not you
know
animal husbandry we can occupy that
space
why because you're not using it right
so in this way they're not suggesting
though that they have dominion over the
whole space
they're just suggesting that they can
move into specific niches
which are undeveloped and develop them
and claim dominion through development
so there's also this sort of third
argument about dominion through
development so those are like the three
i would say main cases that people are
making
about why it's okay to colonize
yeah the last one is is quite
interesting in the sense that you know
the
it is another place where you can see
the intersection of capitalism
and um and
and the these colonial processes that
you're talking about because
um capitalism only sees land as
productive when it's
right when it's productive in a
capitalist way
in fact i think it's from locke and his
discussion of property
that a lot of people draw these these
arguments from
right well we're we're just two minutes
over time
um thank you again for for fielding um
quite a quite a number of questions um
and thank you for
for sharing your work with us and and um
and thank you all for just a wonderful
conversation
and great questions um definitely
keeping me on my toes
trying to get me to remember all the
stuff that i've read or thought about
so i really appreciate that and i'm i'm
glad to hear your questions because it
also informs
the kinds of topics and issues that i do
want to
explore as i develop this book as i said
it's in
it's in its protocol it's in proto
stages right so
um i've i have one chapter written but
i'm looking forward to writing the other
ones
based on the feedback and discussions
i've had here so thank you so much great
all right thank you thank you and thank
you to everyone who
um who attended today and we'll see you
next week
great